thank you Rory for that introduction you
know better than most from your own
experience on the beat the the realities
that our brave officers face when going
up against violent Thugs and other
criminals and the Damage that crime can
do to people and communities and that's
why it's wonderful to be here welcoming
the launch of the public safety
Foundation an organization committed to
making the UK the safest place to live
work and raise a family
this really is the perfect form for
setting out my ethos for common sense
policing
everything that our police officers do
should be about fighting crime catching
criminals and keeping the public safe
my Mantra at the home office is simple
Common Sense policing
Common Sense policing means more police
on our streets it means better police
culture and higher standards it means
giving the public confidence that the
police are unequivocally on their side
not pandering to politically correct
preoccupations it means measuring the
police on outputs such as public
response times crime solved and
criminals captured
it means police officers freed up to
spend their time on proper police work
it means police prioritizing the highest
harm crimes and those that matter most
to the public it means the police making
use of powers like stop and search that
have proven effective in taking weapons
off our streets and above all else
Common Sense policing means officers
maintaining a Relentless focus on
fighting crime catching criminals and
keeping the public safe
and I'm going to speak on each of those
items today
firstly the public wants to see more
Bobbies on the beat and so do I it is
Central to Common Sense policing
everyone who has been part of the
government's police uplift program
should be immensely proud of what we've
achieved in the last few years
many said we couldn't do it but this is
a police success a home office success
and a conservative government success
we've delivered an additional 20
951 officers into policing over the past
three years
there are now almost 150
000 police officers across England and
Wales the highest number ever
24 forces now have more police officers
than they ever had before the program
I'm extremely grateful to police Chiefs
for leading this drive and to those men
and women who have signed up you are now
part of a policing family epitomized by
bravery and dedicated to public service
and safety
as part of the new generation of
policing you will help to raise
standards refocus priorities and
maintain our world-leading place in
policing
policing must remain open to the best
and the bravest whether or not they have
a degree and Common Sense policing means
encouraging the recruitment of officers
that come from and live in the
communities they serve familiar with
local challenges and familiar to local
people that's why I've widened the pool
from which we can recruit by enabling
non-degree holders to be part of
policing it's not about how many exams
you sit or essays you can write
important skills though those are it's
about common sense problem solving and
strength strength of character and
strength of physique
so 20 000 officers is not just a
statistic in a press release
the uplift is already delivering
improved outcomes for policing and the
communities they serve
all forces now have a named officer and
contact information on their websites
meaning our commitment to Greater local
accountability are set out in their
beating crime plan
more police means more flexibility for
forces to do what makes sense locally
which goes to the very heart of Common
Sense policing
a PCC recently explained how the uplift
is making a difference in their patch
they said additional officers have been
deployed into our more rural communities
which allows response times to lessen
and takes pressure off urban-based
officers from covering a wider area
allowing them to focus on localized
crime in one force much of uplift has
been reinvested into tackling rape with
the creation of an additional 119 roles
another Force has used the uplift to
double the size of its knife crime team
boosting its capacity to seize dangerous
weapons and keep people safe
recruiting officers is crucial to
getting more Bobbies on the beat but
retention of existing officers is
similarly important every Force must
focus on retaining the essential skills
and experience of existing officers
we're driving forward work to support
this whether that's through the College
of policing's leadership Center the
mpcc's productivity review or
introducing a statutory police Covenant
which is already delivering tangible
benefits for the police
For the First Time new officers are
given pre-deployment Mental Health
Training to ensure they are able to
manage the rigoras of the rigors of
Frontline policing and Welfare standards
covering the entire Workforce are now
assessed as part of the regular Force
inspection program
it's also vital that policing can offer
a pathway back for those who do leave to
ensure that experience doesn't only ever
leave the building
whilst many forces have deployed
rejoiner schemes at entry level I'm not
convinced that all forces are doing
enough to encourage more senior people
back into policing there is scope to
expand these schemes to focus on key
skills gaps using the standards and
guidance developed by the College of
policing
twenty thousand more police and tougher
sentencing for criminals was a promise
in our 2019 conservative Manifesto It's
what the public voted for
and it's precisely what this
conservative government is now
delivering this is a great success story
but what will really count is what an
expanded police force this new
generation of policing does next
so secondly on police culture more
policing is necessary but not sufficient
Common Sense policing must also mean
higher standards better culture and more
effective policing baroness Casey's
review Into The Metropolitan Police
makes for harrowing reading as I said in
the House of Commons there have been
serious failures of culture and
Leadership
I have the utmost confidence in the Mets
new leadership team Sir Mark Rowley is
right to make the restoration of public
confidence in policing his top priority
and I will give him every support as he
pursues his turnaround plan
but I also expect those with direct
political accountability for Forces pccs
in general and with respect to the met
the mayor of London in particular to
properly exercise their oversight
functions
baroness Casey's review will inform the
work of Lady eilish angelini's inquiry
which will look at broader issues of
policing standards and culture
steps have already been taken to ensure
that forces tackle weaknesses in their
vetting systems I'm currently reviewing
the police dismissals process to speed
up the removal of those officers who
fall short of the high standards
expected of them
that review is also looking at
simplifying the process for dealing with
poor performance and ensuring that the
system is effective at enabling an
officer who fails vetting checks and
service to be removed
the law-abiding public must be able to
know that they can trust any officer
they see
those who are not fit to wear the badge
must never do so and where they are
exposed they must face Justice and be
driven out of the force
I've seen examples of strong leadership
transforming police forces up and down
the country so I'm confident that
policing can and will step up
changing the culture doesn't just mean
addressing the sorts of issues that
baroness Casey identified and raising
Professional Standards to the level that
the public rightly expect
that's a prerequisite a common sense
culture in policing must also mean that
policing understands and reflects public
expectations about the police's proper
focus and function
for too long too many in Authority have
indulged a narrative that crime rather
than being a destructive option chosen
by a criminal minority is an illness to
be treated
this narrative seeks to diminish
individual responsibility and
culpability by holding that criminals
are themselves victims
This Modern emphasis on the needs of
delinquents Thugs and criminals however
cruel their intentions or damaging their
behavior may be displaces the
old-fashioned and just retributive
consideration of the criminal events
themselves and of the effect they have
on genuine victims
people want their government and their
police to be unequivocally on the side
of the victims rather than making
excuses for or distracted by efforts to
redeem the perpetrators
it's something I hear a lot on my
travels around the country on the
doorstep people everywhere tell me that
they want Common Sense good
old-fashioned criminal justice they want
the police to turn up quickly when
they're called they want to know that
when a crime is reported it will be
properly investigated and so I'm glad
that all domestic burglaries now receive
a police response as I called for last
Autumn they want hope that the police
might even catch the crooks
and they want confidence when someone is
arrested if they are found guilty they
will be appropriately punished
because without risk of capture or of
punishment without an appropriate cost
to those breaking the law criminals will
take advantage
that sense of mission must be reflected
in police priorities if the police are
to retain public confidence
sometimes the police simply need to make
better arguments most people recognize
that smartphone clips of a contested
incident circulating on social media
only ever tell a fraction of the story
where appropriate forces should do more
to share body-worn footage video footage
it's vital to public confidence that the
police can quickly demonstrate the
legitimacy of action to counter spurious
claims and trial by social media that
may otherwise follow and allow dangerous
narratives to take hold
maintaining public confidence also
requires that the police be seen as
politically impartial and unequivocally
on the side of the law abiding majority
when police officers stood by as a
statue was torn down when the police
were pictured handing Cups of Tea to
protesters engaged in blocking a road or
when police Chiefs spend taxpayers money
that could have been spent fighting
crime on diversity training that
promotes contested ideology like
critical race Theory
the reputation of policing as an
institution is damaged in the eyes of
the public
some forces have equality teams that
have completely abandoned impartiality
in favor of taking partisan positions
sometimes even engaging in political
argument on Twitter
now I believe in the police
but the policing in which I believe
isn't Riven with political correctness
but enshrined in good old-fashioned
common sense
the perception however unjustified or
unrepresentative that some police are
more interested in virtue signaling or
in protecting the interests of a radical
minority engaged in criminality then
they are protecting the rights of the
law-abiding majority is utterly
corrosive to public confidence in
policing the police must be more
sensitive to this and work harder to
counter it
if police Chiefs approached instilling a
culture of political impartiality with
the same dedication which they approach
in selling a culture of diversity and
inclusion I have no doubt that political
confidence in policing would be
materially improved
thirdly freeing up police time more
police and better police culture is
essential but positive effects are
blunted if the police are not free to
properly focus on policing
that is why over the last six months
I've led a broad program of Common Sense
policing reforms to reduce unnecessary
and inappropriate burdens on police time
Chief amongst those burdens is the
amount of time police spend responding
to mental health call-outs I'm
frequently told about officers waiting
10 to 20 hours with patients who need
medical attention
this is an unacceptable use of police
time we want Frontline officers to be
able to focus on fighting crime and the
work they are trained to do police
officers are not Mental Health
Specialists and the best place for
people suffering a mental health crisis
is a health care setting
this includes developing a national
partnership agreement to ensure Health
calls are responded to by the most
appropriate agency the right care right
person approach sets out a threshold to
assist police decision making on
responding to incidents it's founded on
the understanding that the police should
only be responding to Health and Social
care incidents where there is an
immediate risk of serious harm or
criminality
a toolkit to assist forces in their
implementation of the right care right
person scheme will be rolled out in the
coming months and guidance from the
health sector is also being prepared so
whether it's saving an estimated 400 000
police hours a year by reforming the
home office counting rules reducing them
from 350 pages to almost 50 pages or
reforming the redaction process so
officers spend less time stuck behind a
computer screen we are doing all we can
to support forces to ensure that their
officers spend as much time as possible
on the beat
fourthly
our Public's priorities it's not enough
merely to free up more police resource
Common Sense policing means
acknowledging that police resource is
necessarily finite and that it must
therefore be deployed on the things that
matter most to the public
it's with this sentiment in mind that I
recently introduced a new code of
practice on non-crime hate incidents
taking action for hurt feelings is not
the job of our police
curbing freedom of expression is not the
job of our police enforcing non-existent
blasphemy laws is not the job of our
police
the new code makes clear that personal
data should only be recorded if there is
a real risk of significant harm and
stresses the importance of giving proper
weight to freedom of expression the
public want to see the police focused on
the highest harm crimes and those that
are the priorities to address in their
communities
they want to see the police tackling
violence against women and girls a key
priority to which we've committed nearly
a quarter a billion pounds in home
office and wider Government funding
through 2025. they want to see the
police focused on tackling child sexual
exploitation which is why we launched a
new grooming gang's task force
introduced mandatory reporting and will
be announcing further measures when
responding to the recommendations of the
independent inquiry into child sexual
abuse next month they want to see police
cracking down on drugs and Associated
criminality I'm proud to say that
together with the police we have done
considerable damage to county lines
gangs seizing record amounts of drugs
making 20 000 arrests for drug-related
offenses and disabling 1600 organized
crime gangs since 2021
they want to see the police tackling
knife crime which is why I'm doubling
down on stop and search and launching a
public consultation on Banning machetes
and other large knives that should have
no place on our streets but are readily
available online they want to see the
police treating anti-social Behavior as
a priority crime which is why we've just
published a bold and ambitious action
plan to address this blight on
communities
and they want to see that the police are
on their side when it comes to
addressing highly disruptive protests
which is why we strengthened police
powers in this area this has already
supported the arrest of over 750
individuals by the Metropolitan Police
alone since October 2022
by contrast the police do not want to
see the police to the public do not want
to see the police turning up to
residential addresses to police bad
jokes on Twitter
next on stop and search when it comes to
delivering on the Public's priorities
Common Sense policing calls for the use
of the most effective tools available
without regard to political correctness
stop and search is a perfect example
it's a critical tool which I and this
government fully support the police
using to keep our streets safe I'm proud
to say that under this government it has
never been easier for the police to make
legitimate use of stop and search powers
stop and search has helped to remove
over 40 000 weapons from our streets and
led to over 220
000 arrests since 2019.
stop and search acts as a deterrent by
preventing offenders from carrying
weapons in the first place
and serious violence protection orders
currently being piloted in four police
force areas will provide the police with
enhanced powers to stop and search
adults already convicted of knife and
offensive weapons offenses reducing
violence and crucially saving lives
so common sense policing requires the
police to use all available powers
without fear or favor to keep the public
safe and stop the misery caused by
violence and drugs that is why I intend
to write to police Chiefs in the coming
days to reiterate the importance of stop
and search and the government's full
support for the police's appropriate use
of it
so to conclude I'm immensely proud of
this conservative government's track
record on cutting crime domestic
burglary and robbery are around half the
level they were in 2010. violence and
vehicle theft are around 40 percent
lower than in 2010 and fewer people are
dying from drug and alcohol-related
deaths compared to 2010. but I also see
policing at a turning point with
devastating events like the murder of
Sarah everard forces in special measures
and the problems highlighted in the
Casey report we must all work towards
rebuilding public trust and refocusing
on the Public's priorities
Common Sense policing is the way that we
will do that more police on our streets
better policing culture higher standards
more effective policing focused on the
Public's priorities making use of all
appropriate Powers pursuing good
old-fashioned criminal justice rather
than social justice relentlessly focused
on fighting crime catching criminals and
keeping the public safe
that is the policing that the decent
hard-working law-abiding majority up and
down this country can get behind and
have confidence it
Common Sense policing we can all be
proud of thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much Home Secretary
um I mean where to begin there's so much
positivity actually in there in terms of
what the future holds for us all um can
I just begin I suppose just by
explaining that the home sector is very
kindly agreed to take a few questions
from members of the audience members of
the media you'll be more than happily
accommodated I'm sure by home office
colleagues in a media huddle to follow
shortly so um if we can invite a few uh
get those cognitive juices flowing as
the founder and certainly hosting
everyone today I I'm I'm itching to ask
one myself we have Home Secretary thank
you for the speech we have recruiters I
believe it's 20 000 and I'm reliably
informed 951 offices and I suppose
beyond the sort of message you've
already given is there anything more any
more encouragement you might be able to
offer them in terms of how they can help
make our streets safer
listen I back the police I'm in awe of
their everyday bravery many of us will
never comprehend the risk and the
Jeopardy they Place themselves in day in
day out the number of lives saved the
number of crimes averted the number of
uh people supported and I want to
empower the police that's why with the
policing minister with my team at the
home office we've actively engaged to
listen to police leaders to work
constructively with experts on the
ground on the front line to listen to
what we need to do from a legislative
from a government point of view to
empower to liberate the police to do
their jobs more effectively that's
behind our reforms on policing whether
it's uh the the changes to the uh the
Byzantine and overwhelming home office
counting rules whether it's the changes
to the mental health Arrangements
whether it's trying to free up police
officers who are caught up with
redaction duties I'm in the market for
idea is to go further and faster to help
the police be the best that they can be
thank you home secretary so taking of
someone caught my eye right off the bat
um Donna James just if you could just uh
stand up and we'll get a mic to you um
for your question
thank you very much Home Secretary I'm
Donna Jones police and crime
commissioner hamster in the Isle of
Wight
um the home office have undertaken
reviews of police and crime commissioner
Powers over the last 18 months I wonder
if you can give us an update on the
powers and changes of governance that
may be coming and if that is likely to
include Fire and Rescue Services as well
well the when when it comes to
um the fire service the case for reform
is very clear we've seen a white paper
and the government is going to be
responding to the consultation very very
soon and I think that inquiry findings
and recent reports about standards in
fire have all been shocking and uh have
raised uh the need for uh for for a form
of the system I'm very uh I'm very
supportive of the role of the police and
crime commissioner generally in the
policing landscape they are effective
tools for the public you speak pcc's for
the British people you hold cheese to
account you deliver and you drive better
standards and we will be making an
announcement soon on our response but
I'm very very keen to ensure that we can
raise standards in fire as well
thank you
um Oliver Lawrence in the front row um
do um take a stand and yeah thanks very
much Home Secretary I'm the producer of
the protect and serve podcast that
captures the experiences of police
officers and crime Fighters the world
over something I've been personally
struck by is the sheer volume of people
ready to support policing to raise
standards fight crime and build trust do
you have any views on how policing might
be able to welcome these contributions
from such individuals with such
experience by sort of looking back at
the direct entry schemes that were
previously available
well when I came into the home office
one of the first things we started to
work on was the entry routes and I was
very cognizant of the concerns around
the peqf and the at all levels uh from
new recruits feeling that they were
being un taken away from Frontline
necessary training
um as to police seniors saying this
wasn't necessarily producing the right
men and women for the job and up to the
task and that's why I made it a mission
to ensure that we uh maintain the
non-degree entry route we need to
attract the best the brightest and the
bravest and that doesn't necessarily
mean that you have to have a degree uh
or that you should need one by the end
of your police training we need people
with good judgment strong character and
and fundamentally uh bravery and courage
and those are the right ingredients uh
when when combined with with good
training that can produce excellent
police officers they bring life
experience they bring common sense and
they bring interpersonal skills that are
vital for the job of policing
thank you
Matthew Barber
thank you Matthew Barber police and
crime commissioner for Thames Valley
you've touched on on some of this
already I'm really pleased that Thames
Valley is one of those forces that now
has more police officers than we've ever
had before but you've touched on some of
those challenges around mental health
and the bureaucracy in policing we're
already trying to embrace technology to
ease the burden of of that bureaucracy
but what more can the home office do to
alleviate that burden both on on Mental
Health Demand on on bureaucracy so that
those new offices that we have got in
Thames Valley can be out there
protecting the public rather than stuck
in stations or stuck in a hospital
you're absolutely right to raise this
issue and policing Minister set out
recently in a speech of his about some
of the detail that we're driving through
to free up police officers so they're on
the front line responding to anti-social
Behavior responding to burglaries
responding to victims of rape that's
what we want to see our police officers
doing uh the national partnership
agreement that we are striking with the
health sector I believe is a big step
forward it builds on successful models
that have been uh pioneered around the
country uh particularly the right person
right care model and it means that if
someone is in a mental health crisis the
First Response should be a health care
response not a policing response we want
to stop the scenario of police officers
waiting as I said 20 hours sometimes in
a e uh uh you know looking after someone
who really should be in the care of a
health professional that is vital time
vital resource that I want to free up on
the home office counting rules we've
seen
duplication we've seen uh inefficiency
we've seen bureaucracy
for we estimate that the changes that
we've already announced and we're going
to go further because this is a phased
program already these changes will save
about 400 000 hours a year of police
time that's time that should be on the
streets visible and responsive to the
public
super thank you I'm going to be a little
bit cheeky and I'm going to take just
two or three together
um conscious we've only got a little bit
of time left so
um firstly Harry Miller from fair cop
um
as you as you're probably aware my
organization Fair cob all we want to do
is drive politics out of policing one of
the problems that we have when we
challenge Chief constables is when we
say look you're promoting critical race
Theory you're flying the trans flag Etc
you're not supposed to be political now
they turn around and say we're not being
political so Home Secretary could you
define for us what it means to be
political and why it's important for the
police to stay out of anything that is
political please thank you Harry and
then uh being very cheeky uh one at the
back uh I think it's unless my eyes it's
evenly it's Sam coats
of
thank you I'm actually also articulating
The public's priorities to the police in
your role as from secretary
um but within operational Independence
do you think there's we have enough
structures within the police for them to
reflect public priorities directly
themselves as well so whether that's
pccs I know when Concepts came into
government there was a big play on crime
data and crime Maps hoping that was
going to add public pressure
um you obviously have limits in how much
you can you can direct the police you
can pass laws you can speak from lectins
but do you think that's enough to
reflect the kind of issues that you
think the police should be reflected and
then in the interest of making it making
sure that people I don't know uh get to
ask a question the final one from the
lady uh in the third row just wait for
the mic to to come and apologize for so
many there but I just was Keen for the
audience to feel that
22 different ways to close the crime and
whether you would be looking to simplify
it and also I'd be interested to hear
your thoughts on dg6 and the challenges
that redaction presents within our our
Workforce
great questions thank you very much what
is political well I mean I think uh
contested issues
uh issues where there is a legitimate
debate uh and in which uh freedom of
expression and lawful exchange of views
should be uh not only allowed but
actually encouraged
um at critical race Theory you know
adhering to a particular view on that
that is a highly contested political
issue the police should not be getting
involved in that I would also say gender
critical issues I mean you will you have
experience of this uh yourself but it is
precisely that reason why I've laid new
guidance on non-crime hate incidents we
must allow and preserve ferociously
preserve lawful debate and freedom of
expression and the police really
shouldn't be intervening in what is a
foundation of our democracy
um
operational Independence well we do have
um I mean I think the the PCC structure
is a good one I think that the element
of
um uh
accountability and electability is
absolutely vital for connecting police
forces to the public and fundamentally
public police and crime Commissioners
are held directly to account at The
Ballot Box but I'm very keen to ensure
that the police are responsive to the
Strategic priorities that we set at the
home office that's why I've changed some
of our strategic policing requirements
to include violence against women and
girls and I think that is that will have
an effect on how the police respond to
the priorities that the people have and
lastly you talked about simplifying the
home office accounting rules yes we want
to avoid uh the the duplication of
recording of crime I think that there is
a a wealth of work that we can do we're
going to Embark upon that in our next
phase of Reform of the home office
counting rules and on dg6 well in my
former role as the Attorney General uh
you'll know I I refer change the
Attorney General's guidance on
disclosure we really tried to improve
the rules on redaction I think there may
well be a case to go further because uh
you know there is still a challenge of
police officers stuck behind computer
screens spending hours upon hours
redacting the body worn video footage or
the uh the documents that they are
receiving particularly you see this in
rape investigations and that can really
be a factor that protracts
investigations and makes them very
lengthy to the detriment of the victim
who then may well be more inclined to
withdraw I think it's absolutely vital
that we condense this process there are
other models in other state agencies
that we can learn from and I don't think
it needs to be the way it is currently
thank you very much Home Secretary and
thank you for the participation from the
audience there will be a media huddle in
a few minutes for the media guests we
have
um
before that um I'd just like to thank
you all for joining us I'd like to thank
the Home Secretary for giving us her
time and giving us her thoughts
important thoughts on pleasing and crime
I hope that the foundation today
launching onto the landscape can be a
home for some of these conversations and
discussions back to the home secretary's
point just then about Free Speech
rational thought and being able to
engage on issues of Law and Order I
think it's really important for us so I
hope to see many of you again I hope
you'll spread the word about the work
we're doing and the mission we're on and
then finally really do enjoy any final
teas and coffees uh before we get all
depart and please do extend your thanks
as I will to the Home Secretary for
joining us today
[Applause]